[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en frases 24 pero yo le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido de nuevo seguimos
hablando de la renuncia de la primera
ministra británica listras así que bueno
solamente 45 días como Primer Ministro y
es la persona que ha durado menos tiempo
en la historia de Reino Unido en ese
cargo los mercados financieros
respiraron aliviados pero ahora el
partido gobernante dividido debe
encontrar rápidamente un líder que pueda
unificar sus fracciones enfrentadas la
primera ministra llegó al cargo de
inicios de septiembre su principal
promesa era precisamente impulsar el
crecimiento económico y dar ayuda para
sortear la creciente inflación y la
subida de los precios de la energía pero
su plan ambicioso y sin financiación
hizo que la libra esterlina y los bonos
británicos se desplomaran el sucesor de
Tron sería el quinto Primer Ministro en
siete años desde la firma del brexit que
derivó en un periodo de caos en la
política de Reino Unido la caída de
trocea atribuye a este plan de recortes
Fiscales por 50 mil millones de dólares
que fue presentado sin análisis
independientes de cómo sería financiado
La amenaza a que lo bueno británicos se
desplomaran hizo que el Banco Central
interviniera Para no afectar una pieza
clave para el sector de las pensiones
Jorge el Primer Ministro de Hungría
utilizó un término suicidio económico A
qué se refería con esto bueno se refería
específicamente a los planes de la Unión
Europea para limitar el gas ruso el jefe
del gobierno húngaro dijo en Twitter que
el tope al precio del gas equivale un
embargo total del gas para Hungría
cometer un suicidio económico ayudaría
no ayudaría a Ucrania Esto es lo que
dijo Urban también dijo que se espera un
gran debate en el consejo europeo que se
celebra en Bruselas Entre hoy y mañana
los países discutirían la posibilidad de
imponer este tope al precio del gas ruso
con el objetivo de que los precios de la
energía de alguna forma bajen Bruselas
abogada por un tope flexible y temporal
que ponga un techo mi principal índice
de referencia para el hidrocarburo otra
idea es obligar a los países a comprar
de forma conjunta al menos el 15% del
gas para llenar los depósitos de cara al
invierno del año 2024 aunque esta
iniciativa esta iniciativa ha sido
bastante criticada por el gobierno
húngaro que se opone a que sea
obligatorio participar en este sistema
Hungría argumenta que ya tiene contratos
con Rusia e incluso alardea de que su
economía mejora mientras la de otros
países sufren o sufrirán por las
sanciones contra Rusia desde antes de la
guerra Hungría que depende muchísimo del
gas y el petróleo ruso se opone a
cualquier sanción o limitación a la
compra de hidrocarburos de Rusia Jorge
ya hay datos de la actividad económica
en Argentina el este el estimador
mensual que publicó el gobierno de
Argentina muestra que la economía de
Argentina se estancó en agosto Aunque el
estimador subió un 6,4% respecto al año
anterior la variación respecto a Julio
fue el 0,4%,
un conector de hoteles y restaurantes
mostró una leve mejora al igual que la
explotación de minas y canteras el
gobierno se encuentra actualmente en
negociaciones con las principales
empresas productoras de alimentos para
lograr congelar los precios las
negociaciones están a cargo del
secretario de comercio Matías tombolini
quien Busca crear una canasta compuesta
de entre 1500 y 2000 artículos cuyos se
fijarían en los entre 90 y 120 días
vamos a Asia porque el yen cayó a
mínimos frente al Dólar y el banco de
Japón tuvo que intervenir Así es el día
en cayó a 150 unidades por dólar un
nivel que no se registraba desde agosto
de 1990 la divisa continúa cayendo pese
a los intentos del banco de Japón que
derivaron en una intervención en el
mercado en septiembre pasado en lo que
va del año el que en el retrocedido un
23% frente al Dólar Esta caída es
impulsada principalmente por la
divergencia en materia de tipos que
mantiene la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos y blanco de Japón que está
provocando una fuga hacia los bonos de
Estados Unidos el rendimiento del Bono a
10 años alcanza el 4,15% en Estados
Unidos mientras que la rentabilidad del
Bono japonés al mismo plazo se sitúa
apenas en el
0,25%. Jorge Snapchat se desplomó en la
bolsa de hoy porque bueno la empresa
reportó el crecimiento de ventas
trimestrales más lento de su historia
atribuido a una disminución en el gasto
de publicidad de parte de los
anunciantes según bloomberg las ventas
del tercer trimestre aumentaron un 6% a
1.130 millones de dólares esta cifra es
ligeramente inferior a la estimación
media de los analistas que esperaban
aproximadamente 1.140 millones de
dólares la empresa en agosto recortó el
20% de su planilla y redujo proyectos
que no contribuyen al crecimiento de los
usuarios o de los ingresos de la
compañía Snapchat cerró a 10,79 dólares
por acción este año ha caído un 77%. y
Cuál es nuestra cifra del día Jorge
tiene que ver con esta batalla legal
entre elon musk y tiene planes de
deshacerse del 75% de la planilla que
trabaja en Twitter hasta dejarla solo en
2000 personas esto según publicó hoy el
Washington post y que era uno de los
temores de los empleados de la red
social Jorge muchas gracias por la
información económica y ustedes se le
den gracias por acompañarnos ya viene
Ángela Gómez con el debate pero nos
vemos más adelante con más noticias